حوالي 5 ٪ من النساء يعانين بشكل طبيعي من
انقطاع الطمث المبكر بين سن 40
و 45 وفقًا لوزارة
الصحة والخدمات البشرية في دراسة جديدة
أجرتها جامعة كوليدج لندن تشير إلى أن
المزيد من الجنس قد يجعل انقطاع الطمث المبكر أقل
احتمالية.
جمع باحثو العلوم المفتوحة بيانات من ما يقرب من
3000 امرأة وخلصوا إلى أن أولئك الذين
يمارسون نشاطًا جنسيًا أسبوعيًا كانوا
أقل عرضة بنسبة 28 ٪
لانقطاع الطمث المبكر مقارنة بأولئك الذين مارسوا الجنس
أقل من شهرية ، وتقول الدراسة إن أولئك
الذين مارسوا الجنس شهريًا أقل احتمالًا بنسبة 19 في المائة.
لتجربة انقطاع الطمث المبكر
من أولئك الذين لديهم معدلات منخفضة ، يشير
المؤلف الأول للدراسة إلى أنه بدون ممارسة الجنس
لا توجد فرصة للحمل ، لذلك
قد لا يستثمر الجسم في الإباضة ،
يقول الباحثون أنه في حين أن انقطاع الطمث أمر
لا مفر منه بالنسبة للنساء ، فإن هذه النتائج هي
مؤشر أولي على أن توقيت انقطاع الطمث
قد  كن متكيفًا
استجابةً لاحتمالية الحمل
في ساعة اليوم  دقيقة ealth أنا ماندي جيثر